So what is the great challenge or
question before us?
I think of it as the wall within each
one of us.
The war between apathy and action.
Apathy is very seductive.
It is wreathed in false facts.
Facts such as there is no progress in
Africa.
There is no progress anywhere.
The is,
um,
no.
All African leaders are corrupt and all
aid is wasted.
These are holes,
facts,
the datasets.
D datasets do not exist to justify them
yet they bounce around unscrutinised
they need to be challenged because
they're wrong.
Against that is the call to action.
Not just mindless action,
but evidence based action or factor in
some call it and that's a growing
movement of informed global citizens.
You take action based on the facts to
change government policies or make
informed consumer decisions that result
in building on facts of progress.
Facts such as we have in fact hearth,
extreme poverty.
There are now 9 million people on
antiretroviral drugs funded by you.
You didn't know that,
that you're saving these lives through
funding these drugs.
Thank you.
Malaria deaths,
deaths down because of insecticide
treated bed nets,
again,
funded by taxpayer funded eight
programs,
a smart aid programs,
and above all progress generated by
great leadership in Africa by some
governments in a bubble by citizens in
these countries and across the
developing world who are demanding
better results.
The chance we have now is through the
Millennium Goals renewed to build on the
fact of progress armed citizens across
the world with scorecards to measure
governments and they're holding them
accountable.
That is the great prize we have before
us to generate this army of,
uh,
informed global citizens who will build
on the facts of progress and avoid
terrible facts that could exist by 2030.
If we don't get this right,
to which world you want and which set of
facts do you want to live in by 2030.
Thank you.